-How are you, buddy?
-Hey, man. I'm good.
How are you?
-I'm very good.
I do miss having you
here in person
because you often show up
in sartorial splendor.
Did you dress up at all
for us today?
-Eh, no, not really.
Just sort of a green shirt
today.
You know what I thought
you were going to say
is I thought you were going to
say you missed my hugs.
-I do.
I do miss your hugs.
But mostly while
I'm hugging you,
I just want to have your style
[ Both laugh ]
What a very well-appointed
office, though.
Is it safe to say you're
in an office right now?
-I'm actually not in an office
-Are you in a closet?
-Yeah, this is -- [ Laughs ]
I'm not that opulent.
No. It's like a little --
It's like a TV room, basically
like a media room.
-I want to ask this question
You obviously -- None of us --
I'm not dressed up, either
for this
because we're living in a time
where a lot of the standards
are lower.
I know you just celebrated
an 11th wedding anniversary.
Is a celebration like that
during a pandemic,
does it take the pressure of
a little bit?
Because you cannot, obviously,
roll out the red carpet.
-Yeah.
Yeah, totally.
No, it's an opportunity
to kind of be like,
"Well, I guess I can't --
I guess I can't really --
We can't really
do anything for this."
You know, it's sad to thin
of that as an opportunity.
No, but we did.
We kept it very simple.
I mean, I think last time
I was on there, actually,
we talked about my wife and I'
10th-anniversary trip.
-Yeah, which was a bit of a --
I guess a boating mishap, right?
Like, you were outdoors.
You were doing all the thing
we used to do.
And let's be honest, this year
went probably better for you
-Uh, yeah.
Well, anything where
I'm not throwing up
off the back of a boat is --
is much better for me.
-You are --
You're in California right now
which is, based on everythin
you see and hear,
a very hot place to be
right now,
maybe a little bit of a scar
place to be right now.
How are you?
I know your kids are 8 and 6
How are they handling school
How are you guys
getting through it?
Uh, I mean, everybody's
taking it in stride.
I mean, look, I can't complain
I'm financially stable.
So there's people in far worse
situations than I'm in.
You're right, though, California
does seem to be on fire.
I can't seem to stop my eyes
from watering.
I'm assuming that's
because of the fires.
Either that or it's
I'm crying about something
that I'm, you know,
subconsciously unaware of.
-Like a super-repressed thin
is coming out during this time
-That's possible.
It's possible.
No, I mean, we're teaching
our kids at home,
kind of splitting our days
between teaching the kids
and, you know,
trying to get our own work done.
And, you know, just kind o
riding this thing out.
It's not so bad.
I mean, luckily,
I actually like my wife.
We enjoy each other's company.
So, um, it's --
-That's good.
I'm finding the same.
It's a very nice thing
to realize, like,
"Oh, we're doing good
with all this time,"
which is very nice to find out
How do you --
How are 8 and 6 insofar
as they can handle attention
spans of doing school right now?
-That has been a struggle,
for sure,
you know, I mean,
especially the kindergartner
I mean, he's very --
he's a very fidgety guy.
He's active.
He's very social.
He wants to be, you know,
moving around and stuff.
And Zoom's not really conduciv
to that.
And, you know, my kids are -
I mean, they do okay,
but they're also a little bi
the kind of kids
that would, like,
sit in the back of the class
and, like, hope that the teacher
doesn't ever call on them
or notice them,
which is a lot easier
to pull off when you're on Zoom.
As a matter of fact, actually,
the other day,
I looked in the playroom,
which is where my kindergartne
is doing Zooms.
And the Zoom call was happening,
and I could hear it.
And I looked in there,
and he was just, like,
draped across the chair,
like, in a Superman pose.
Like, not paying attention
to the Zoom at all.
Just, like, doing --
I don't know what he was doing
But he was not doing school.
-It's good.
It's good to give kids roo
to make their own choices.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is very exciting.
You know, I think both you and I
are excited and delighted
that there even is a Season
of "A.P. Bio."
For those who don't know,
it was an NBC show
that then got picked up on NBC's
new streaming service, Peacock
And you guys had shot 8 episodes
of 10 when this hit.
Do you remember that day, like
when the decisions
were being made?
'Cause they were being mad
pretty quickly.
-I remember there was a lo
of talk about it.
I remember we were
a little stressed
about being able
to finish eight.
'Cause I remember thinking
if we can get eight out,
I think you can release
eight episodes.
And it almost feels like
a full season of television.
You know, so luckily,
we were able to get that done.
I was also in the middle of,
I think, editing the episode
that I had directed
a couple weeks prior.
So I was in the middle
of editing that.
And then, you know,
things shut down.
And, you know, there was a par
of me that at the time
I was like, "Oh, well, this will
be a good opportunity
to just, like, rest,
'cause I'm tired."
-Yeah.
-You know, but luckily,
we got eight good episodes out
-It's a delight to watch.
One of the most jarring things
about watching it right no
is that it takes place
in a high school.
And I'm wondering
if that is refreshing
for people to look at a school
where no one is worried abou
things like social distancin
or if it is like a horror movi
to just watch people
touching each other
and bumping into each othe
in the hallways.
I personally find it the former,
obviously.
-Well, yeah, it's strange
because you see that
and it seems like
such strange behavior now
to see, like,
people talking face-to-fac
and, you know,
hugging each other
and, you know, being
in proximity with each other
without wearing masks.
So it's both, like, horrifying
and also like you pine for i
at the same time.
I don't know that there's
too many things you can watc
where you're both
horrified by it
and you pine for it
at the same time.
-You have this incredible
supporting cast
with Patton Oswalt,
obviously Paula Pell.
One of the things that's
really fun about this season
is you spend more time
in the classroom.
This is one -- You know,
it's one those shows where -
It's three seasons, but it's
the same kids in the classroom
And there's a really nice
chemistry with you guys.
It must be fun to, you know,
not only get to know
the characters better
and know how to react to them,
but to get to know
the actual actors, as well
-Oh, God.
I adore this cast.
I'm the luckiest man
in the world.
Like, I love working
with these people.
I get to laugh all day long.
I mean, every single --
all the students,
all the other teachers,
everybody is a --
you know, a scene stealer.
And I mean that in a good way.
Like, they're all so funny
And it just -- it tickles me
I'm having a blast, you know
And the kids especially,
because they were, you know,
younger actors,
it's been really fun
to watch them
get more and more confiden
as, you know --
In the third season, they came
in so sure of themselves.
And, you know,
that just makes them
more comfortable and funnier
and, you know,
you can kind of riff
and improv with them and stuff
They've just been amazing.
-You are one of our
most excellent thespians
when it comes to playing
likeable jerks.
And I mean that sincerely.
Jack on this show is.
But, you know, over the course
of the series
and certainly more this year
like, he seems to like
where he is more
and like the people
he's around more.
Is that more fun to play?
Or do you enjoy the more
irascible where he started
-I think it's been more fu
for me
because it allows me
to play notes
that I haven't been able to play
as an actor very much.
You know, I mean,
my other character
on "It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia"
is in no way, shape,
or form warm.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-To get to play that is nice
And it's also nice because
it creates a lot of conflict
for the character because,
you know,
my character still really
wants to think of himself
as this elitist
Hollywood philosopher.
You know, but he's slowly
being faced with the fact
that maybe he could be happy
with just being
a hometown Toledo boy,
which is also
his worst nightmare.
So there's this great tension,
you know, within the character
that he wants to be one thin
but he feels something else an
he can't quite give into it.
But he's definitely, like --
I think he's really growin
close to these kids
and to the other faculty and h
really loves these people.
And it's fun to play that.
He just can't admit it.
-You mentioned Dennis,
and it's incredible to say
but there's a -- it's lookin
very likely now
that there is going to be
a 15th season of "Always Sunny,"
which is just -- I mean,
it continues to be
an incredible accomplishment
but that doesn't mean
that it shouldn't be noted
So congratulations
on that, as well.
-Thanks, man.
Yeah, no, we're very lucky
I mean, hopefully the show
is now at a point
where it just kind of
feels ubiquitous.
It just is and always will be.
You know, I think there ar
some people who --
You know, I mean,
I've met kids that are like,
"I started watching your sho
when I was in junior high.
And I'm like, "Dude, you're 30."
-[ Laughs ] Right.
-The show's been out
a long time.
-It's very funny to think
of, like, "60 Minutes"
in the same class
as "Always Sunny,"
which is like, "Yeah, I thin
that show's just -- It's on.
Hey, man,
always great to see you.
Love to the family.
And I hope to see you soon
-Yeah. I hope we get to --
I want to give you one
of my warm, you know,
bodily hugs at one point.
-One of those classic hugs
Thanks so much.
-Good to see you, man.